you
the human body contains organs such as
bones the brain heart and reproductive
organs the basic cells that give rise to
all of the different cells in these
organs are called stem cells one type of
stem cell is an egg cell from a woman
that has been fertilized by a sperm from
a man
this single cell called a zygote is the
first cell in a developing human being
it's also called a totipotent stem cell
because it can form any type of cell in
the body as well as the umbilical cord
and placenta after a zygote has divided
a few times it becomes an early stage
embryo called a blastocyst embryonic
stem cells come from the cells inside
the blastocyst
embryonic stem cells are pluripotent
this means they can form any cell in the
body but not the cells in the umbilical
cord or placenta
in the lab embryonic stem cells are
donated from leftover embryos created
during in-vitro fertilization in vitro
fertilization is a procedure to help a
woman become pregnant
another type of stem cell is an adult
stem cell small groups of these cells
are found in some organs such as the
skin after birth and into adulthood
adult stem cells are multiple n't this
means they can only become a few
different cell types related to the
organ where they're found for example
the skin contains a small number of
adult stem cells that can divide to
create new skin adult stem cells or they
can become more specialized skin cells
to replace those that are lost due to
cell aging or damaged
in the lab scientists can now induce or
cause a regular body cell such as a skin
cell to change into a pluripotent stem
cell like embryonic stem cells these
induced pluripotent stem cells can
become any type of cell in the body
scientists study stem cells to learn how
and why they become many different types
of cells in the future these cells may
be used to regrow tissues and organs
that have been damaged by injury or
disease
stem-cell therapy is a procedure that
uses stem cells to treat a disease or
condition currently stem cell therapy
only treats diseases and cancers of the
blood in leukemia for example the
patient's bone marrow makes many
abnormal white blood cells that can't do
their job to fight infection
over time these abnormal cells crowd out
the production of healthy white blood
cells in stem cell therapy for leukemia
called hematopoietic stem cell
transplantation a doctor will take a
sample of blood or bone marrow from the
patient or a donor in some cases donor
blood may come from a baby's umbilical
cord after it's born these tissue
samples contain healthy Hamato poetic or
blood-forming stem cells then doctors
will give the patient chemotherapy drugs
or use radiation to kill the abnormal
white blood cells and their stem cells
once the abnormal cells are gone the
doctor will transplant the healthy
hematopoietic stem cells from the tissue
samples into the patient these healthy
stem cells will make new blood cells
including normal white blood cells which
will allow the body to fight off
infections